the newly signed american rescue plan
being put
into action president biden signed the
1.9
trillion dollar covet relief package
into law on thursday
and the legislative victory for the
president is already being felt by some
americans
stimulus payments of up to fourteen
hundred dollars for individuals are
showing up in bank accounts
this morning while the plan has the
support of the majority of americans
no republicans in the closely divided
congress voted in favor of the bill
underscoring the deep partisan split in
washington
christina raffini is our washington is
in our washington newsroom christina
good morning
good morning michelle this is the
largest federal aid package
passed in generations aimed at helping
struggling struggling americans with a
much needed infusion of cash
or actually checks direct deposits or in
some cases it will come from a prepaid
debit card
and that money has already started
showing up in statements over the
weekend
or as one service industry friend posted
on his facebook yesterday
just got my stimulus check woohoo
flying high on his legislative victory
president biden went
wheels up for a weekend away at his home
in wilmington
but not before taking a victory lap in
the white house rose garden
this bill puts working people in this
nation first
surrounded by state flags and a
selection of socially distanced
democrats
who helped push the 1.9 trillion dollar
behemoth
of a bill through congress without
republican support
i know how hard it is to pass major
consequential legislation particularly
when we only have such minor small
majorities in both
houses republicans disagree calling the
bill wasteful
and its spending too broad this wasn't a
bill to finish off the pandemic it was a
multi-trillion dollar trojan horse full
of bad
old liberal ideas despite the criticism
a cbs news u-gov poll found most
americans
support the coveted relief bill in
addition to those 14-hundred dollar
direct
payments it extends federal unemployment
benefits
provides funds to reopen schools and
allocates billions for vaccine
production and distribution
which president biden said is ahead of
schedule all
adult americans will be eligible to get
a vaccine
no later than may 1. but in order to
make that happen
governors on both sides of the aisle
said they will need better supply chains
and many many more doses i think getting
to the
president's objective is absolutely
doable
but it's going to require a significant
increase
in available supply
now next week president biden and vice
president harris will head out on a
campaign
to different cities across america to
tell people what exactly is in the bill
and how they say it's going to help get
the country back on track
jeff christina thank you very much